what I'm not going to be doing is using
Justice Department resources to try to
circumvent state laws on this issue
despite the Obama administration's
claims that it would not circumvent
state medical marijuana laws what the
president said during the campaign
you'll be so surprised to though will be
consistent with what we wheeling here in
law enforcement raids occurred on to
West Hollywood dispensaries in March
2011 reasontv arrived at the Zen healing
collective to find the storefront shut
down and agents from the Sheriff's
Department Los Angeles Police Department
and the Federal Drug Enforcement
Administration hauling out boxes from
the back according to a DEA spokesperson
warrant served where federal and law
enforcement took one individual into
custody which may result in arrest this
occurred only a week after a vote
authorizing California to tax medical
marijuana it's still unclear why Zen
collective and alternative herbal health
services were targeted for raids or if
Los Angeles is in for more raids in the
near future agents at the scene refused
comment for you with the Sheriff
Department of the DEA yes can we talk to
somebody